Jhaal
Ajay Ko
Hello Hello Everyone Applied To Welcome You Want To
Days When Today Will Discuss About
The Role Of Big Data In Bioinformatics
Ansh Application Will Talk About Various
Opportunities And The Resources To Learn
And Practice Cancer Pattern Required
For 10
-
Yogic Community
Responsible  For interactions with a
part of the community to
start with talk to you are you
spider-man company will work with academic
and
readers to develop is used to make
bioinformatics
research program result of
liberation-in-life
Numerous economic institutions have
participated in content  Volume Action
Thriller Review and Project Design
Logic National Program Running in Different
Regions with Over 1000 User Names and YouTube
Scroll IT with Local and Regional
Coordinator
Local Program
Online Sources Adopting a Need of
Students and Research
Programs for India Flag
March 2018 Live Status from Top Toe
Review It has been completed by
participants from one country in over 30
Subscribe
that data science for biomedical do and
comprehensive train and mix data in this
amazing experience
for all
problems from medical background with her
2g
and chemistry
and what
is the meaning of the topper of  Medical Research
Center
for
the Director of the
People
Who is the
Real Subscribe to the
Family of Development Objective and
Applied for a Pivotal Talk About Article
Dr. Harpreet Kaur brings expertise in the
application of statistical machine learning
techniques of biomedical data and development
of production tools and data.  Basis of
Wealth Select Curriculum Development by
Informatics Center Science Course and Front
Part Complete by
Dr. Mohit Majumdar Experience for Your Information
with Multiple Equations
in Peer Reviewed Jewels and Collaboration
Industrial
5105 Person Help in Developing
Collaboration with University Man to Lead Us
in This
Big
Guide you through the
project and give way to sources also on
communication skills in order to enhance your
mother daughter in
law with me request you all please like
share and thank you navya will
try like this to
ajay
and ayush give all minute and to sign  Up on the
portal data is what is requested for two
days without discussing part for the
introducer half velvet
that genetic and log den please
tailors by sending one and may alive
four drops of
daily one latest features
festival laptop and volume ko
jhaal
loot
and other  Final Order for Details of
Creative Venture Sign Up Please Latest
Ninth Soldier of Bus Syndicate Chart Basoda
pk.com To
Ek
Superstition Computer Destined Death He Has Also Been
Updated There Profile
Profile
Picture
Social
Profile
Course You Are
Going Through A Program To See How Much You
Have completed the sources of water can also be able to
download the certificate in the
profile section inside the course portal I would await your
response in search of
scientific Sukhbir Kaur and
Jhal
New Delhi Noida Pin Code etc. Responses
in this chartbook
and whose work completed a significant
for go  Ahead with the completion of work
profile and would like to
talk about various sources to present only
amitphysique loan portal Dr. Mohit
testing discourses and the details of
discussion is positive view of model to
switch how they can navigate to the portal
and understanding of different types  of
domain and also get a non practice the
course step on the amitphysique don't
portal you be able to find various courses
project in various domain of amazing
religious cultural religious and fat
genomic gain with the first president you
start with this post posted by Vijay
Molecule Court  Has Been Designed To Give An
Introductory Explanation Of The Various
Drama That Dadi Office Logic Of Words And
Understanding Of Various Development Begins
With And Go Ahead With Specialization In The
Molecular Course You Will Be Able To Get
Understanding Of Nomadic Tribes And
Securely Maybe Not
Understanding Of  How To Gain With Lord
Great Saints In The Molecular
On The President
Of
Karo To Take Medicine
And How This Technique Improvised Mode On This Introductory
Fluid Guru Pyari Sadh
Specialization Track Panel Get
Understanding By Different Going To The Various
Loop Also Provide All Side Practice More And
More than 200 gr and alone how to unlock is
the interpreter result and half inch writing
speed were going to launch to in this page
all main and all events piece or mix recently it good to discuss about
you
can get the inside of what is the role  Of
biology and speech
genomics study basically in space and what
is its relevance and how you can learn more
about such a per introductory regret pet you can gain
wealth and definition of water no
dayaram mini students from your college
and not from bioinformatics but biotechnology
and  Microbiology But You Seem
Bioinformatics Aloe Vera Serving
Spread in All Districts of Women Right
Now and Problem Important for Every
Biologist 2109 Pillars Basic of
Bioinformatics Sudhir Vigyan Chapter
Research and Informatics in User's
Application for
Password I Don't See the Question
Introduction By the Grace of Lord Given  Them
inside what is
the role of bioinformatics
translational to begin with understanding recommends that you do
long difficult love quotes to understand why you can go subscribe our Channel subscribe and
subscribe the Channel
which will also take you through the various lord
and affection control switches  In bills the
portal world record court playground
and make you practice chief of the thanks a
very easily which you can access and go alone and the
portal effect
feel is the program switch on line guide
programs in different subscribe to complete your
introductory edition to definitely move  Ahead With
Specialization
Subscribe
Research
Research Fellowship Which Talk
To Wise To Talk About Program Course
Every Day And Subscribe Roller To Subscribe Now
Desk One To Hold Course
Of Research Solitude Item Tangri
Sonalika For Others To View And
Hello Everyone Started Discussing About Doing Her Long
To Lakshmi  Launcher for love you all to all
subscribe
skin under graduate and post graduate
course and
subscribe to
is and right thank you writing's a
whatsapp first time
laetitia little useless coming and
objective question answer is the thing about your
department world latest understand
mode indicate date from which  You Can Benefit from
Technology Advancement in
Technology
Sleeping on the Road use the Video then
subscribe to the Page
if you liked
The Video then
subscribe to the
two and
Flash Light On Line Quotation Medicine The
Future of Medicine for Machine Learning Now
Informatics Using Code Singh Sajwan
Interested
subscribe to
bhindi
ki petrol lakshmi sharma screen for you to
discuss mode to economiyon ka
playlist sunao doctor preet kaur mamta kal doctor
inka sharma thank you at every turn
doctor shyama for being or tears want to talk to you
all about it is related to what  We Do
Meeting To Discuss The Meaning Of Meaning Of
Treatment Now
Skin
More
And Only For Every One To Learn The
Harappan Medical Discovery The Future Of
Research And Technology I Think It Is The
New Generation Of
Subscribe
And Machine Learning
Do
SUBSCRIBE MY
CHANNEL
SUBSCRIBE AND DEVELOP CHANNEL
SUBSCRIBE
CHANNEL
ALSO
JOIN US ON YOU CAN FIND APOLLO NEW
SCREEN AND IT WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH MUCH THE
DIFFERENT
Pinpointed
Sonalika Please
Pendu Salman Fashion Can Discuss The Results
And
Help Him For Any Questions  History is
made
A great soul exists with start Such
circular operative Vinod Three This
calibrate A rose redoing between Chandigarh
Group of college students Jobs In this quest for
the oldest of The soil request Everyone
broken Indicated A
microphone
Director Venu This question is
incomplete Thank
you all
the  Art of
living in this awareness among students
and faculty
subscribe
utilizing the
material needs
that and a policy research institute has
guide on Play Store which enables any one
to take and guidances are also available complete
online and with his meetings were
doing right now in this  Process will
learn about the things which fruits from the
1622 Development of Advanced Technology
Knowledge
subscribe
[Music]
our
Channel
subscribe
to the Page
if
you liked
The Video
then
subscribe to
the Page
that a Doctors Understanding Your Help
Get Help in Medicine
4000 Have Peer
Voice  Sexual
Eid To Online Questions
Page From All Around The World Today All
Indian
Specifically Punjab
Team Members From Punjab School [
Music]
subscribe
to
the Page if you liked The Video
then
subscribe to the
Industrial Thank You
Well Minute Students To Get Better
Opportunity And There  Careers Light
Switch Steam in here in this The
Bana The
Video Recording To
The Point Of Having
Different Topics For
Discussing About
Shopping
subscribe for More
Video Subscribe Important
Meeting Key
Date
Questions A It's Upside Down Moderators To Mute The
Participants Were Not Able To Snatch The
News Channel Saurav Coming back to the topic
of having understanding of different
areas let's move
with the introduction of talking about the
first time
in the
history
of important research currently I am
working with students
subscribe
to be lit apni something in the field twink
opportunity great  Opportunities in good
companies and there is no road to rock so I
scientific connect all the people and help them do the
best with resources available in the
next few years
Paper to learn about this new technology
and talking about application
data machine learning New
Delhi
today  To
solve the question is the
Subscribe 496
Ek To Britons And Related Opportunity
Of
Viewers Feel Voice Of Learning And UPA
Buddhibal To Learn About This And Make Them Maximum
Use Of The
Bio Medical And Health Centers Offered
Lutia Doob
School
Possible Technology subscribe
The
Video then
subscribe  to
the
people in every way
Paun Inch
Ye Paun Inch After this training to check
pimple sharing website you will be lost in
thought and different types of world news
subscribe
application form
use different types of
knowledge of how is the what are the
solved problems
due
To Some
Interesting Facts Did
You Know Thanks
Quantity Research And Interests Of The To
New Discoveries Of Haze And These Few
Publications Coming Out Of Whose Initiative From
Students High School Students
In This In Mind Power Fuel Tank Warning
Subscribe Talking About When They Talk About
Subscribe
Like and
Rule and
Subscribe Our Advantage Talking about
Question and Not
Automated Low Intensity Planning So all the
information technology to the statistical
model is coming from the biology and
technology its cutting more and more clear
Subscribe Thank
You Must Give Something
is the number of  subscribe and
subscribe the Channel
subscribe Interview Mein
9999 The
Protein I Am Now Having A Setting Condition That Certain
Time When A Person Having Cancer
Luta Day Routine Sa Giving Water
Different Size Comparison In Today In This
World And
Request For
Designing
Subscribe To Develop This Into
Something
Is
The Thing Look Paste Talking About The
Benefits Of The
Developed Countries
Subscribe
Like This Champion Find Total Inward And
Friends Dolphin International Understanding
Of Dattatreya Mechanism For Justice To Impossible
In Research It Health To Understand
More And More About Solving
Minute Vikram And Vinod Now Battery Saver  To
Back Tab Solution Tourist Destination With That Understanding Is
Drug Discovery Talking About The
Middle And Talking About Some Different Different
From A Little Bit Different
Just Give Very Basic Understanding What
Is
The
Importance
Page Subscribe [
Music]
These Two Cups Of Flour Computer Scientist This
Point  Se Match And Engineers Tuesday Bank
Apne Company Talking Tom Company
Subscribe People Whose
Knowledge
2012 Talk And You Have A Clear
Understanding Of
Subscribe My Channel
Subscribe
For Example In Do
Subscribe My
Channel
Ko
Subscribe
Hua Pita Mix Dual Pai Bhi Viral Sirf And
Small Infectious  Decisions After About Seervi
Dahej
Page Channel Subscribe Our Channel Take A Little
Water Mechanism
subscribe to the
Page if you liked The Video
then [
Music]
subscribe to
the
Page if you
liked The
Thank You for Your Report Application for
Data Science in Different Fields Pain  Banerjee
Differences The
Size of Test
Series
Payment
Subscribe Like and
Subscribe To
Variety Show Volume Is How Little Is
Earth Millions Of Nucleotide And
Protein Variety
President Of The World And Candidates Assembled
In Any Way To Vinod Yadav Different
Variety Of Data In The Loot Information  Will
Get All Data And What Are The Advantages
Channel
Subscribe In
Hindi Different Aspects
Of
All
Subscribe Function Of Subscribe And Subscribe The
Walking Dead Another
1000 Project Is Pentagon
Officer
2009 Actor
Mid Day Give Something
Like Every Day In The
History Of Genetic Research
Center
Subscribe Machine 709
[Music]
For Toilet Indore Worn In Indore Saenger
Institute Institute In
Cambridgeshire Temple Campus In Intensive Study
Request Be Full Of Resources With Same
Great Idea
Surya 19 Technology About Despite Being Different
On Early Initiative In Direction From
President
Free Andher
[Music]
Subscribe Invented The Information
Cheap
subscribe this Video plz subscribe
Channel
subscribe kare
text me talk about
notification when you go to doctor doctor
give what is the
information
channel
subscribe
Molecule Aaj Independence Day you can find all the information about  Different
Types of
Eggs
Subscribe
Limited is the British Company
Tattoo Successful Students in Universities and
of the Richest Community Today Due to
Research Using Aadhaar Platform to This
Data is Available in Deposit Rates
Registering
for Brain Research in the
Air and Water Project
subscribe
The
Video then
subscribe to
subscribe our Channel
subscribe and subscribe
the Channel Please subscribe
Me group of all students want to
Different Geography For
Example From This You Can Get Data From China
Samridh Hai The From India Stage In This Situation They Have All The
Information And Which Can Point Personally
Sports Live
Web
Scribble To Options
Page 9 Tags Page 10 Coming After And Future
Of This Industry
Timilai  And Virus And Antivirus Software
Performance Lot Of Thanks
Daughters To Information Can Get You To Do
Subscribe My Channel
Health And
Helped 4,000
Meaning To Get
Pimples And Side Effects To Please
Subscribe
For All
Subscribe And Attachment For More Words
In The
Water Treatment
Limited
Subscribe Button To
subscribe
to
the Page if you all Interactive They will give oo wo to aab
150 grams please do I want to tell you all about
inch thick its president of width
so can you tell me what is the
president of birth so 13 more like what
you think  E Om
Shanti Waiting For Return Gift Hamper
Recipe Light Of
K
Superintendent Medicine Is The Amazing Approach
Site For Disease Treatment And Prevention De Take
Into Account Of Individual
Validity In The Life Cycle On This Position
British Approach Will Alarm Doctors And
Research Suite More Accurately Water
Treatment  And prevention strategies for
specific disease or particular digit will
work in which group of people choke away in the
top most corrupt people talk about in the context
of clinical trials of
difficulties in the contrast 218
Subscribe 158 is to
depend because of updates and research Navya pause
to
Enter New Year of Medical Practitioner Ved is
going to be
available for the doctors and this helpful
in truly reduce Ajay Answer is the causes of morbidity
and mortality worldwide
ID holders to cancel evidences
the color coding in the year and month
pregnant lifestyle  And
Subscribe Subscribe To
Video Channel
Question Drivers Malik
Driver Intellect And Issues But People Of Identified
A Certificate That Give
Knowledge Adhishwar Apne Due To Understand What You See Them In This Aspect
Of
Understanding About This Point Press
Subscribe
Data
Type In Blue When  You see that all the
information can give
water cooler
cooler
subscribe to kunwar you have started
understanding of all the other type of the
types and how the affect
body or in fact in health care systems
to in this type of looking
looking and different type of  The
year
to the
volume to the
subscribe and
share
subscribe kare
hai but whip treatment diagnosis show having
good diagnosis very important for disease
treatment without and having and detection
system very songs will help first woman
live to cancer it division
more to related soft do  You Know
Diagnosis Can Help People To Survive With Sthal Hai [
Music]
That And To Learn About This Technology
Sports Doing His Daughter To Experiment
And Inspiration Mouse Where You Want Him
Planting This
Cancer Tissue And Learning About Its
Production And Learning About How They Ca
n't  Visible
in the Animal Models and Clinical Trial
Information
[Music] About
Getting Information Now
School Information and
Subscribe to my Channel
Difficult Challenge Satpal Ji Post
Dwar Par Hain To
In and In Raw
Medium to All Over the Universe It is My
Video Research Program  To Video from
this wayBeech About Learning About
Different Types of Technology and Application
Appointment Association President Popular
Infectious Diseases and Quite Difficult These Can
Be Used to Learn More and More About
30,000 Difficult Infectious Diseases
Sweater Also Avoid Na
Dham Kuch To Win
Win
The Self  Defense
Posts Fail Under
Subscribe
Subscribe To Robert Enable By The Way Can Study
Dash Light Of Birth
Sexual Who Code File Path Easy Simple
And Highly Accurate Next Generation To
Them Technology So This Virus Code Unit
And College Students
The Information And Subscribe
Online Repository Of  All Indian
Chief
Minister again in this world in shoes setting
stop son
online subscribe to YouTube channel now to receive
new
updates about
you might be from different
types on Friday maximum to this
technology zsr loan about micro wire this
micro organic and international
environment
suggestion
this community
subscribe  Specific
microbiota example in
different type of the
richest
community in talking talking about the
bacteria rule
but everywhere in quick hearty what
is fitting depression stress withdrawal expectation
of living of birth so
now school give
winners
and wanted to
give some
video to me  Do Do Do
Subscribe
You Have This Very Different
From The
Not Help
And
More Have A More About Money Siddharth
Astrobiology This Page Setup Running Very
Address 2014 Changes And Join Us Today Evening That
Online Test This Change
Positive Vibration Spring Roll
Benefit Of 110 Temple Run
More
subscribe and
subscribe
the Channel
Position Changes
Na Scientific Research Knowledge Deposit in
Word
[Music]
Quikr Charles and Diana 108 Might Have Been
Overwhelming for Beam Too
Characteristics How Lighter Session and What You
Think About Fashion
Android Operating System Launch Mention So What
They Want To  Discuss 2031 The Application
and
Subscribe and What are
the Different Uses
All the Best We Are What We Do
University
Research Training and Research Institute
and Research Based Learning
From
Back to the Giver
Another Opportunity to Meet Log in Fiction
Media Cell and Supreme in the Winter
Session  Where It's Very Nominal
34.22
Must Subscribe
Arvind
Singh
University And Interested Candidates
For
The Liberation Doob
Script And Application The
Population Help Channel
Subscribe To
Participate In This
Half Real U R C U P U R Pimpri
Sexual The Navya Elections Till 2030 Mails  And
He To Understand Or Of The Industry
To Briggs And Technology University Se
Zinc
Subscribe
All The
World And Develop Problem Different
Areas Of Union
President Me To
The Union President
Chandigarh Hua
Queen Avengers In The Attack And Celebrate
Industry Other Industries
Allotment Coming Up In India A  Startup
Important Andare
Subscribe Now In Demand Everywhere Around
World Subscribe
And
Subscribe And Undergraduate Program
Share And
Subscribe
Thank You Know How To Subscribe
My
Channel
Subscribe In The
Middle Ages
Ducati Voucher And Vaibhav Or The Amazing
Significance Was Available That Dr Prakash
131 Platform  Where they are doing all the
inheritance of data in the west coast in the
old approach excited whatsapp open
kar loongi
subscribe
idli sandwich
subscribe thank you for your time and
subscribe
my channel
and
development at
main aapke liye meri darta out of form of
medicinal uses  Of Information For
Entertainment Best Choice Questions Of
Physicians And Subscribe Quite Right In
The Answer Subscribe To This Video Channel
Definition Of President
For The
Question A Like
Subscribe And
Development Center In New
Delhi On
200 Vipin Rai Jitendra Chat To
Typing Question About And Chief
Proctor  Dr
[Music]
Ki Agar Chahiye So Ayush Dr J Sahitya Hi
Advisor Dr Renu's Success Thank You So Much
Profit Mohit Ko Secretary One Should Talk Porn
Big Data Anand And Packed In This Alternative Laut
Budha Bioinformatics
Install Unchanging Course Of Research Post
Students Who Are  Interested To Learn More About
Different Peace And To Get Aa Hai
Net Practice And Amitphysique Loan Portal
And All Interested To Join Research
Fellowship Program Director Mohit Has Already Told Ht
Connected After Renuka
Sharma Due ₹10 Only Quality In
Department Of Research Chandigarh Group Of
Colleges Mohali India And After Renuka
Represents Arise Department CEC And Would
Like To Like Stage Doctor Renuka And
Mother Would Like To Take You Observe Previous And
Help You Out Alone Know If Know But You Don't
Drink
110 That Sonalika
Thank You Movie Plant Nice Station Power
Students At Some Point Someone From It's
Request All Of You Shouldn't
Connect Me If You Want To Internships
Penetration In This You Can Do In Like You
Have Voted To Power In This Training 3261
Trainings You Can Connect Me And Movie
Tense Sonalika You Can Go For  Your Short
Term Projects From Some Projects
With Him You Can Read With Different
Posts For Your Interest Agriculture In
Health Care In A Mistake Anyone You Can Choose From Thank You
Sonalika Hain Andhvishwas Mar
Swarajya Doctor
Mohite Judge Dhami The Great Episode 235 In
Force For Jobs With Talking  About where they have tried to
integrate a lot of
libraries from the tool café multi store runway yes
analysis and the results and from its
object loan course you will be able to give the
understanding of how does
ResourceSat-2B interpret and use other
research to  Behave Like A Demon Pipe Lines
With Animals After True And How Are The
Pipelines Effective Work Oil Co So Just
You All True One Day Mobile Prize Bid Understanding What People Are Talking About
Pipe Lines When You Have Different
Sorts Of Tools And You Just How To  Do And
Id M Id Wood
Robin Uthappa That's All And This Twister
Toolkit Scientific During Vegetable Start The
Pipeline Data Is Already Uploaded And The Next K
Button Ruby Use Purvi Highlighted
Selection Light Come The Best Romantic And
Action Like To Invite Doctor Harpreet
Tourism And Talk Previous  Video Explain
It's All To You Very Much Better Detail Subscribe To Advance
Channel Like You To
Show Screen's Settings To
Like And Share My PM
And Amaze Pe
Hai Mean By You All Cancers Poster Question
Tubelight To Hearts In Four
Drops Morning Happy To Answer
OK Sir One IS
Visible in
To-Do
List Play Karo Jhaal Jhaal
Hello Hello
Everyone My Name is Harpreet Kaur and
I Hope Tasty Informatic Joe Front Neck
Line Curriculum Development Research Consultant
with Fine But Where Are Mustung Research Fellow
Hindus During Subscribe subscribe
and
subscribe the  And adb school
like this particular platform at the
speed and
use this point
is don't
like this
that you and on a work we example ko
like almost one TV doing this you can't
directly do you can't from Sunday
Times you're not the  Question Program
Subscribe to Channel Now To You To You To You To
You To You Can
Improve
Pipeline
subscribe
to
Tide of Tita and Jyoti Patel Platform
Will Offer You Facility Which You Can Prove
Certificate Just Click
Start Play List
That Sophia On Vacation Solid Example
Project  Pipeline we are already downloaded the
data has not been uploaded by clicking on
star plus to you will directly depend into
for example welcome to your
funds pair input your deposit
reference
like this swelling
in
to-do list
automatically
Video then
subscribe to
the
remove water  From A
Bluetooth Library Definition Before Running
And Politics Switch Layer Liner Tractor 245
President Prime And After It's To Make Them
Stable Democratic Algorithm Mother Will
Remove All The Actors And Non Technical And
Technical Tips
Light
Bill To
Remove The
Question On
E Want Your Deepest Tomorrow Evening  Plain collective
soldiers * alarm which reduce reference
no Sudhir Vats option research getting its due to hot
very
obscene fair and pink and it
different from a I
so many alarm which real and reference
days
indiscriminately next
point to point
to
you will find the
number of  This channel
like this is the
line particular
and you will find the
like
this the audit to but I am K Pandhe Verma simply is goli to quickly and Chinese expression table
data from sequence kidnapping is the to
bike setting on the end of
e will you complete  And Pipeline Bulk Per Old
Example Pipeline Vishal Privacy Already
Ramanandan Also Upload Pipelines Objection
Certificate
Immediately While You Are Doing This
Analysis On Nutritional Diet Will Take Some
Time Before Returning Home Made Sample This
Subscribe And Take Off
The Download Different
Types Of The Bill After Running This
Is
The Example You Will Know The
Man Like Me
Delhi's Defense Percentage 86 Per Cent For
Most Of Temples But Samudra Shark Slide
77.34 Donkeys Donkeys Donkeys
Example You Will Find
Difficult Download New Hath You Need To Go To Talk
Or Stupid But Apk Bollywood  The
Volume To Table
That Equity's Fix Time Okay Listen This
Simple Chinese Presentable This Look Question In
The Forest Problem And
Robbery
In Temple Items For Different
Olympics-2012
Subscribe
Like Like Like Like Like This Thank
You
Will Get All The
Running
From This Particular And
Loot Half Number of Medical Research and Types
of Craft for Example 98100 Upper
Primary School
Example
Normal and
Other Districts You Will Find the
Machine Machine Machine
Machine
Learning Chinese
Utility You Understand to Normal
Is Your Data Into Various Types of
the Day
One Point Dedicated  Section Dabega Virus
Person And Different Types Of Pollution
Interested In
You Will You Can To Number Of Cancer
And
You Would Like To
Thank You
So Much For Giving One Under
You All The Best
All The
Best
Doctor's I Think They All Want I Want To
Hear  From
Side To Thank All The Students Who Want To Learn More About
Road Looking Forward To Your Participation
And Short Tricks Difficult Initiative Of
Doctors White Coat Software Doctor In
Remedy Thank You So Much To All Participants
Of Water Slide Pass Doctor Inka Naam Women On
Jhal hai
ki white females yes yes
thank you everyone is between you and in the meeting and very
nice to meet you all dresses for joining
barf